They say that there are no new ideas in Hollywood.
And to that, we say: good.
After all, why waste time coming up with a
bad new idea when you can just remake a classic,
old, good idea?
If something was a hit once, chances are it
will be a hit again, which is why Hollywood
is currently working on another slew of awesome
reboots.
Here's a look at some upcoming remakes that
will get you pumped.
Little Shop of Horrors
The original 1960 version of Little Shop of
Horrors was directed Roger Corman and featured
a brief appearance by a masochistic Jack Nicholson.
"This is gonna hurt you more than it hurts
me."
"Oh goodie goodie!
Here it comes!"
The film inspired an off-Broadway musical,
which in turn gave birth to the 1986 movie
directed by Frank Oz.
Now, it looks like Tinseltown is opening up
Little Shop for a third time.
Deadline calls the new project "a fresh version
of the 30-year-old Frank Oz-directed film,"
but on this go-round, Greg Berlanti will be
the one shouting "action."
If Berlanti's name sounds familiar, that's
because he's the producer behind TV hits like
Riverdale, The Flash, and Supergirl.
Hey, if anyone can defeat Audrey II, it's
the maid of might!
The Fly
If you're a horror fan, you know the original
Fly starring Vincent Price hit theaters back
in 1958.
"ah."
And in 1986, David Cronenberg decided to give
the tale his own grotesque spin, casting Jeff
Goldblum and Geena Davis in one of the nastiest
monster movies ever made.
Now it looks like J.D. Dillard might very
well create his own insect monstrosity.
In March 2017, Variety reported that the up-and-coming
director is in talks for The Fly, coming off
his critically acclaimed debut Sleight.
Dillard told SlashFilm that if he ends up
directing the film, he'll be focusing on the
characters and not the effects, saying,
"I think if you look at a lot of remakes,
and the ones that may have not been as successful
as others, I think often times the wrong pieces
are remade."
White Men Can't Jump
In 1992, Woody Harrelson and Wesley Snipes
joined forces in the classic basketball comedy
White Men Can't Jump, written and directed
by Ron Shelton.
The film was a major hit, earning over $90
million worldwide, so it's no wonder Hollywood
is interested in a remake, with Black-ish
showrunner Kenya Barris producing and writing.
And if there's one thing we know from watching
Black-ish, it's that he's got game.
Does he think he can do better?
"Bring it on, bad boy!"
First Blood
We all know Rambo can survive in the woods,
fight the Viet Cong, and shoot helicopters
with explosive-tipped arrows.
But can he sing and dance?
Well, it looks like we're about to find out,
as the action movie icon is headed to…
Bollywood.
Starring up-and-coming actor Tiger Shroff,
the First Blood remake will be titled Rambo,
and according to Entertainment Weekly,
"[The movie will follow] the last surviving
member of an elite covert unit of the Indian
Armed Forces who returns home to find that
his land is in the midst of war."
Filming on Rambo has been delayed for now,
but they do have a cool poster, so here's
hoping it comes out soon!
Charlie's Angels
The classic 1970's TV series Charlie's Angels
was relaunched as a successful film series
in 2000.
But Sony apparently figures it's been long
enough for yet another try, as a new big screen
version is reportedly set for a 2019 release.
Nobody has actually been cast in it yet, but
Elizabeth Banks is set to direct, and Kristen
Stewart and Lupita N'yongo are rumored to
be in the running for roles.
The Cannonball Run
Despite being critically panned, 1981's Cannonball
Run became a cult hit, spawning a sequel thanks
to a massive all-star cast that included everyone
from Burt Reynolds and Roger Moore to Sammy
Davis Jr. and Jackie Chan.
Now it looks like the racers are revving their
engines again, as Universal is bringing The
Cannonball Run back to theaters.
According to Deadline, Thomas Lennon and Robert
Ben Garant of Night at the Museum fame might
write the script, while Dodgeball director
Rawson Thurber is attached as well.
Here's hoping they somehow tie Captain Chaos
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"help is on the way!
Justice will triumph!
Dun Dun DUNNNNN!"
Alien Nation
The 1988 film Alien Nation was a big enough
hit that it spawned a spinoff TV series.
So it makes sense that Fox might want to do
a remake.
However, according to director Jeff Nichols,
his upcoming remake of Alien Nation isn't
a remake at all, telling ScreenCrush,
"It doesn't really have anything to do with
the original."
Turns out Nichols and Fox decided to slap
the Alien Nation label on a totally unrelated
project the director was developing, because,
why not.
We don't know what the story is about, but
at least fans know what it's not about, so
that's something, right?
Flash Gordon
In 2015, it was announced that Matthew Vaughn—the
guy behind Kick-Ass, X-Men: First Class, and
both Kingsmen films—would be remaking Flash
Gordon.
There's just one problem, though - Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Vaughn told Collider,
"The only problem with Flash Gordon is Guardians
kind of stole what I would have liked to have
done with it."
As a result, the upcoming Flash Gordon film
has been delayed while Vaughn tries to figure
out how to do it.
Good luck, Matt!
"BONG!"
Nosferatu
Before Twilight... before Blade... there was...
Nosferatu!
The first full length vampire movie starred
Max Schreck as the rat-like Count Orlok, an
undead demon who sent audiences into hysterics
in 1922.
Nearly a century later, the film set to be
remade by The Witch director Robert Eggers,
starring The Witch actress Anya Taylor-Joy
and famed creature specialist Doug Jones as
the vampire.
Just when the film will go into production
is up in the air, but we can't wait to see
it when it finally arrives.
Pet Sematary
According to Variety, Paramount is planning
to remake the classic Stephen King story Pet
Sematary, with Starry Eyes directors Kevin
Kolsch and Dennis Widmyer set to direct.
No word yet on who is going to star in it,
but given the spotty track record of recent
King adaptations, here's hoping this one is
more like It and less like The Dark Tower.
Yet another King remake?
"It's really going to happen isn't it?"
"Oh yes it is."
Logan's Run
It won a special Oscar for its visual effects,
but in the four decades since Logan Run's
release, the movie has largely been forgotten
by mainstream audiences.
Directed by Michael Anderson, this sci-fi
film was set in a futuristic society where
people are executed once they reach their
30th birthday.
"Well no one has to die at 30!
You can live!"
It's a sci-fi premise that's begging for a
modern take, and we'll soon get a remake courtesy
of Simon Kinberg, who wrote X-Men: Days of
Future Past and X-Men: Apocalypse.
No word on who will star, but according to
Deadline, they may make the lead a woman this
time around, so it should be interesting to
see what direction they head with it.
Highlander
Among immortal swordsmen, there can be only
one.
But if we're talking about movies about immortal
swordsmen, well, that's a totally different
story.
There have been multiple live-action Highlander
movies, a couple of TV series, and a cartoon.
And now it looks like Lionsgate is finally
moving forward with the long-awaited remake
of the 1986 cult classic, with John Wick director
Chad Stahelski attached.
And hey, no matter what happens, it's guaranteed
to be better than Highlander 2!
"Ah."
Fantastic Voyage
It's one of those science fiction classics
that's largely been forgotten by modern-day
audiences.
Starring Raquel Welch and Donald Pleasence,
the 1966 hit Fantastic Voyage follows a group
of scientists who shrink down to microscopic
size, climb inside a miniature submarine,
and set sail inside a comatose patient, hoping
to save him from a brain clot.
It's a pretty cool premise, one that's just
perfect for a remake—and fortunately for
sci-fi fans, Guillermo del Toro is the man
who'll bring this tiny story to the big screen.
Originally, the movie was supposed to hit
theaters in 2019, but production was paused
so del Toro could focus on promoting The Shape
of Water.
Things appear to be back on track now, though.
So assuming this really is the Oscar-winner's
next project, this sci-fi adventure will definitely
be worth the wait.
Flight of the Navigator
Tron wasn't the only cut sci-fi hit Disney
released in the '80s.
They also put out Flight of the Navigator,
which was about a kid who is abducted by aliens
and implanted with all sorts of secret knowledge
that the government desperately wants their
hands on.
Now, Lionsgate and the Henson Company are
teaming up for a new adaptation, and after
briefly considering Colin Trevorrow in 2012,
they're hiring Joe Henderson—the showrunner
behind Lucifer—to pen the screenplay.
And with the Henson Company's involvement,
we've got our fingers crossed that we might
get to see a few cool puppets.
"You're very lucky slave, only the emperor
can drink you essence."
Okay... maybe not.
But hopefully, we'll at least get Paul Reubens
back as the wisecracking computer.
"Don't forget to feed Brutus!
Two all beef patties, special sauce, lettuce
cheese, pickles onions on a sesame seed bun
...whoa, huh huh!"
Cleopatra Jones
While not as famous as Pam Grier, Tamara Dobson
left her mark on the blaxploitation genre
with Cleopatra Jones, a kickass 1973 film
about a woman who works as supermodel as a
cover for her real job: spying for the U.S.
government.
It's a pretty fun premise and perfect for
a remake, and that's why Warner Bros. has
hired Misha Green, creator of the WGN show
Underground, to pen a script and create what
Deadline calls "the female answer to James
Bond."
Sounds promising!
West Side Story
While it might not begin tonight, production
on a brand new West Side Story will start
in the very near future.
This remake of the 1961 classic will be directed
by Steven Spielberg, making his first musical.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Spielberg
has been wanting to direct this film "for
decades," and now he's teaming up with screenwriter
Tony Kushner to make his dream come true.
Spielberg and Kushner previously worked together
on Lincoln and Munich, and as Kushner has
won an Emmy, a Tony, and the Pulitzer, we
can safely assume the script is in capable
hands.
As for the cast, the filmmakers sent out a
casting call in January 2018, searching for
actors ages 15 to 25 to play the lead parts
of Tony, Maria, Anita, and Bernardo.
And thankfully, unlike the original film,
Spielberg plans on casting the lead Latino
characters with actual Latino actors — which
is cool.
48 Hrs.
Hot off Saturday Night Live, Eddie Murphy
made his feature film debut with 48 Hrs.,
which basically created the "buddy cop" genre
while becoming a box office smash.
The action comedy is widely considered an
'80s classic, but now it's getting a 21st-century
spin.
Jerrod Carmichael is set to star and co-write
the project, while brothers Josh and Ben Safdie,
who previously directed the critically acclaimed
films Heaven Knows What and Good Time, will
be behind the cameras.
Rabid
When it comes to body horror, it doesn't get
any better — or bloodier — than the work
of David Cronenberg.
Though most of his films are famous, back
when he was still rising through the ranks,
he directed the forgotten 1977 cult flick
Rabid, which presaged the whole "zombie plague"
strain of films.
And now it's going to be remade by Jen and
Sylvia Soska.
Known to horror fans as the Twisted Twins,
the duo is set to begin filming the Rabid
remake in April, 2018 with what Indiewire
calls a "modern and relevant spin from the
woman's perspective."
We sure can't wait!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!